[Music]
for 21 seasons on american pickers mike
wolfe and frank fritz were one of tv's
most popular duos but now it's all over
here's everything you need to know about
the ugly feud that will change the way
you think about american pickers
in retrospect signs of a major schism in
the world of american pickers were
present way back in the spring of 2020.
at first season 21 of the series kept up
with the show's format of mike wolfe and
frank fritz traveling around the us
looking for treasure and moving on to
the next stop but starting with the
episode ghost to the west which
originally aired on september 7th
2020 fritz was nowhere to be seen
neither mike wolff nor store manager
daniel kobe gave any explanation for
fritz's extended absence and american
pickers first and barely acknowledged
that anything was different
even as danny was also suddenly promoted
to on location picking partner
due to pandemic lockdowns and
restrictions on tv production
season 22 of american pickers didn't hit
the air until january 2021
nearly a year after those initial fritz
free episodes debuted
with fritz still gone from the show
worried fans finally realized that the
american picker star might be gone for
good
finally in july 2021 frank fritz emerged
and broke his silence explaining why he
was no longer a part of the show that
had made him a reality tv superstar
in an interview with the sun fritz
claims he didn't leave american pickers
but rather stop participating in the
series due to medical reasons
he said i didn't leave the show i
finished shooting and then i had a
little back surgery and the pandemic
came
he also claimed at the time it's up to
the network whether i come back on the
show
on top of a condition with his back that
required surgery fritz also suffers from
crohn's disease
a serious and chronic inflammatory
disease that affects the digestive
system
he also recently lost more than 65
pounds which he attributed to exercising
more and quitting alcohol but though he
claimed his absence has had to do with
health issues fritz said his former
partner hasn't had his back
frank fritz said that his falling out
with mike wolf whom he says he's known
for more than 40 years
began quietly some time before news of
the american pickers feud reached the
public in 2021
fritz recounted to the sun i haven't
talked to mike in two years
he knew my back was messed up but he
didn't call me up and ask how i was
doing that's just how it is
the lack of communication seemed to make
some other issues of resentment bubble
up for fritz particularly tension with
wolf or the production of american
pickers
fritz alleged the show was tilted
towards him one thousand percent but
despite calling out wolf fred said he
accepted his role as plain second fiddle
as he explained
it's like you've got aerosmith and
there's steven tyler and he's the front
man
i found my spot i'm second and he's
number one on the show
that's no problem with me but maybe he
does have a problem you can't ride this
bike by yourself
you have to have two people to balance
it
on july 21st 2021 the history channel
made it official
a representative from the network told
entertainment weekly that fritz's long
tenure on american pickers had indeed
come to an end
according to the rep not only were there
no plans to bring fritz back to the
series but he also no longer fit into
the franchise's quote big picture
at that point mike will finally weighed
in on fritz's absence without
acknowledging any of the criticisms that
have been levied at him
he released a statement wishing his
former co-star well writing
i've known frank for as long as i can
remember he's been like a brother to me
the journey that frank danny and i
started back in 2009 like all of life
has come with its highs and lows
blessings and challenges but it has also
been the most rewarding
i will miss frank just like all of you
and i pray for the very best and all
good things for him on the next part of
his journey
you have to get used to change though i
mean that's that's the that's some of
the biggest arguments
you and i have when we're on the road is
change man
well mike wolf's statement on the
ongoing frank pritz affair was brief
polite and professional remarks from
another individual in the american
pickers family were a bit more dramatic
on august 2nd 2021 danny colby the third
cast member of american pickers released
a statement on the behind-the-scenes
drama via instagram
and she clearly picked aside alongside a
photo of herself and wolf colby wrote
i'm proud of how you have handled the
last 12 years and look forward to many
more years of rolling around this big
blue marble together
i'm truly saddened for the loss of frank
on the show i'm incredibly sad for his
struggles i wish things could have been
different but we must be accountable for
our actions when we cause instability or
pain and suffering to others
colby further alluded to the
behind-the-scenes situation by saying
frank caused so much pain for himself
that it has been hard to watch
i truly hope frank receives all the help
he needs
by august 4th 2021 fritz returned to the
sun to issue another blistering
statement calling out his former co-host
once again
not mincing words in response to wolf's
statement on his departure from the
series fritz said
mike's statement was both somebody wrote
it out for him i don't believe in ten
years he said five nice things to me you
know
unless he was cutting somebody else down
and we were both laughing fritz also
told the sun that he's not done fighting
for a way back to the spotlight
thousands of people want me back they've
got a petition to get me back on the
show
i could go either way and find a new
show have something new and have just as
much fun
so look out for that possibility frank
fritz fans as for mike wolfe the
american pickers host did not
immediately respond to fritz's comments
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you